[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of the
very hyped up
netflix show space force starring steve
carell
and it's created by greg daniels so you
got the big brains behind the office
here
it's exciting to see steve krell again
in the comedy medium so i'm first gonna
share my general thoughts about space
force and then i'll go episode by
episode here's the thing about greg
daniels
so he had done the office he also did
parks and rec
and this year he had two shows come out
in upload and space force now uploads on
amazon
prime i wasn't crazy about it and space
force here
wasn't crazy about it however the
positive spin to it is that
for some reason greg daniels struggles
with his first seasons of his shows
in particular the office season one is
one of the weakest seasons
and parks and rec season one is pretty
bad like
awful bad and then it picks up season
two and kind of finds its footing
and you kind of definitely see the same
thing here in space force
i think the hope of maybe seeing the
same kind of trend repeat itself where
will get better
is that the last two episodes is where
it starts to find footing and actually
get
to be a decent show but the slog to get
there
is brutal the thing that blew my mind
and how terrible it was was this
accent steve crow was doing as the
character of mark
it felt like he was doing michael scarn
from the office
but doing it the whole time and it
seemed like he was struggling with it it
seemed unnecessary i don't know what it
was adding
i don't know if it was a defense in this
fear they might have had to separate
themselves from the office and not seem
too much like michael scott
but it was atrocious and it wasn't
consistent either there were scenes
where he drops it
and by the end of the season he really
doesn't do it at all which was much
better just do your regular voice
there's no reason to have this like
michael scarn thing going on at all it
was just cringy
i felt like i was watching threat level
midnight from the office
but not in a good way like the actual
film michael scott had made threat level
midnight
and here's the issue it's a big netflix
project there's a lot of money into this
you see that even the cgi and the monkey
episode 2
looks really good the sets look great
it's got a big cast
but you can't skip on the writing the
writing's got to be good it's got to be
funny it's a comedy
a lot of times production value and cgi
isn't
really the best bonus for comedy what is
it really doing it's still just
empty and hollow when i started greg
daniels shows i'm always excited to see
who are these new characters we're gonna
meet who are gonna be the interesting
characters
and i think the biggest disappointment
of the show for me was
there was not many i was like why are so
many people in the show
so normal and that goes to having dr
mallory john malkovich's character
as the second lead here it's too much
screen time for a character like this
to have the character who's like the
teacher who comes to calm down all the
crazy kids and students as one of the
main parts of getting a bunch of screen
time
really brings the tone of the show down
because he's such a low tone and he's so
serious and he is knows everything he's
the smart character
i don't understand why we got so much
time with him it made the show not funny
it made it just
all right we get it he knows everything
it's that humor they kept
just slamming down our throats here of
like correcting the idiots in the room
but it wasn't in a fun way
it was in like a bratty way a snobby way
which can get tiresome
it feels too much like robert california
from the office way did not enjoy which
was james spader's character and i just
think
it would have worked better with dr
mallory if he takes a little more of a
supporting role instead of just so much
focus on him it was just
way too much and that's what's so
interesting i thought episode 4
when mark actually goes to this test
moon site and we meet
jerome and the characters in that tent i
thought that's when the show was at its
funniest because that was the strangest
characters that's
what i was missing this whole season
look at the character of jimmy yang
that he plays chan he's another straight
character just like dr mallory it's like
too much around it it's like this is a
comedy people like they're all over the
place in this show i don't understand it
and i really always enjoy ben schwartz
but they give him some really bad lines
at the beginning of this show
it's cringe level bad and then i start
questioning
am i getting ben schwartz burnout i
don't know i don't want to say that yet
but it's feeling that way a little bit i
feel like
someone's got to give him a little more
to do than just this same kind of
crutches he falls on
how many times can ben schwartz do the
robot where it gets unfunny anymore
and that's the tough thing just about
comedies in general now you know
it's one of those things where it feels
like the show is also a little scared to
let loose where the office was
fearless and it weren't a different time
now
you know everyone's so careful with
comedy and it sucks because
it's the same problem in stand-up right
now too where if you're so worried about
offending people in comedy
i feel like that's problematic and i
think humor
is supposed to be offensive in a way
because it's us all laughing at
ourselves
and it's scary when you're tiptoeing
because then you're just getting
not funny boring and you can be funny
without being offensive that's totally
true but we know where steve crow and
greg daniel's comfort zone is and where
their magic is and it has to be where
they don't feel like
they're walking on eggshells and i felt
like they were walking on eggshells
throughout this season
there's a reason dave chappelle's
stand-up special on netflix do the best
and the most popular because
he's fearless he's still doing what he
believes is funny and he's not
worrying about reaction to it i also
thought mark's daughter
aaron got way too much screen time as
well and i
really hated the character they had her
kind of start having a little bond with
in duncan that she'd always tease
it was like a awful version of april and
andy dwyer from parks and rec where
aaron was like the smart aleck sarcastic
type
where duncan's just this idiot but the
problem is
duncan is nowhere near andy dryer
because andy dwyer
had that charm to him he was an idiot
but it was a lovable idiot and there was
some sense to him where this character
is beyond dumb
where it's not even funny it's just
silly to even watch him it's like
they need to drop that character next
season now some bright spot characters i
like though i like lisa kudrow as the
wife here
i thought she shined and i wish she had
more screen time
it obviously felt a little too close to
the concept of george booth senior from
america development when he goes to jail
but
it was still really funny and i thought
her scenes were consistently great
and i really like tawny newsom here who
plays angela
i thought she was really good and
there's a lot of charm to her character
and she's a little goofy so i think
she's someone who has a lot of potential
down the road for this show
but another area where things fell flat
was
her relationship with chan here was just
too much time spent on that too and
there's
zero chemistry who really cares and
again
my problem with the jimmy yang character
he's just not funny he's too straight
of a character that it's not enjoyable
to even watch
and it sucks because i didn't expect
moments in the show where i'd actually
face palm
to myself but i did when there's this
sequence in episode 8 when aaron
is running in line with the prisoners
that she meets that know her mom
and she is reminded how much she
loves running and how it helps her and
it's like the most corny cheesy thing
i don't know who thought of that there's
a lot of cheese in here however there is
some good heartfelt stuff in it there's
too much of it in the show but there's a
lot that works i do think it works
how they connect aaron and mark both
being loners
and how in episode four it was really
sad to watch he had all this pizza come
and no one came to her party
and mark in the same aspect is alone or
two his wife's in jail he's always at
work
and i think there was moments with
mallory and mark that worked as well
how their relationship went back and
forth in the more serious tones of the
show so in a quick breakdown of
really episode by episode to me episode
1 and 2 were really bad
and it was really disappointing because
episode 1 was written by greg daniels
and steve carell maybe the dance scene
with mark
was ruined by the trailer so i'm not
going to hold too much against that
a lot of twitter humor here that feels
like it should have been made a couple
years ago
and just lazy jokes like when he says to
chan about the samurai sword come on
so i'd give episode one like a five and
then i thought episode two was the worst
of the season which is so disappointing
because greg daniels himself
wrote it this is where the accent steve
crow is doing is really highlighted this
whole episode it's cringe level
and this whole monkey bit felt like a
two-year-old wrote this
i don't know what the hell they were
thinking and especially to have it as
episode two to really
tune people out of the show and maybe
give up on it one of the worst lines
they have ben schwartz say in this
episode is i know this chimp i manage
his facebook page
so this episode i gave it to then
episode three is where we have the
budget hearing
i thought the handmaid's joke was lazy i
thought having a character
exactly replicate aoc was too on the
nose
in the same way that they have like the
president obviously is trump in this
story but they're not going to say his
name
sometimes i think with comedy when it's
so relatable to we see every day we want
to escape from these things but to have
it
exactly the same sometimes just feels
like again
too easy like how many trump jokes
already been made by comics it's it's
the laziest area to just go
this is the same thing with late night
show host too i just wish there was more
cleverness to it and creative thought
and they even double up on jokes here
like that
don't even work where erin says at one
point about the people in this town how
stupid they are
she's like who am i supposed to talk to
if i don't have a dirt bike or sniffing
glue she literally
makes a derp bike joke twice in this
episode which is just
really just not great so i gave that
episode of four however
episode four was maybe i thought the
funniest episode of the season this was
written by lauren houseman
it was the best writing of any episode
because you added these characters i
wish we saw more of and were interesting
i wish these were the characters from
the start
with jerome playing that didgeridoo i
don't want to keep comparing it to the
office but it felt like that magic of
the office for a second when they're in
that tent
and steve carl's running around because
it lets the characters let loose
and they're in more of like an enclosed
space where we see mostly at space force
everything's just
big open it's almost attaches everyone
and kind of takes away from
the conflict that office always have
everyone was so close together but here
having them in this small space really
let steve kerrell shine i love lisa
cudrow with the cornrows here
and i love the bread and butter bit
especially with the dream sequence for
some reason him imagining
his family and him in a car singing it
was great so that one i'm gonna give a
seven
episode five was creative in its own
right it was a space flag episode i give
it props for that
i was trying to do something different
it's always fun to see a rivalry too
kind of like anchorman
where you have the air force versus
space force there's a lot of potential
in that concept
however it didn't really hit the mark
there it kind of
got just stale and it didn't try enough
either sometimes with the show there
wasn't even
an attempt at humor which was odd and it
got a little over sappy at the bid with
him giving the patch to mallory and it
kind of felt out of nowhere so i'm gonna
give that one a six though it was decent
episode six the spy i thought was one of
the worst i thought it went back
downhill again the show
and i already brought this up but how
aaron and duncan's relationship with him
just
teasing how stupid he is and he's
clearly really dumb but it's just again
a lame attempt at andy dwyer in april
from parks and rec and it's just not
enjoyable to watch at that point i felt
like giving up
and the only reason i kept probably
continuing this because i was reviewing
the show and this episode was the most
guilty of just not even trying to be
funny it was just
odd to watch so i gave that one a three
episode seven continued a lot of the
trend that i didn't like with aaron and
duncan
there's this one cringe worthy scene
where they're talking about him having a
lack of imagination
and her bringing up ronald mcdonald in
our surfboard at that point was like
what what who's writing this you you
wonder if anyone in the writers room or
on set
is questioning like this is bad can we
just even
tune it up on set and a lot of stuff
didn't work like with the edison james
team coming in and the woman who runs
that team has in a conversation with
mark and he's talking about his
handshake machine just felt flat to me
and it was
overdrawn it was a long scene so i give
that episode three as well and then
episode eight the conjugal visit
what a great concept to have an episode
centered around this where he would
visit lisa kudrow
to have their sexual relationship while
she's in jail it had so much potential
here to be great and it was funny when
he was going on the trailer steps and he
falls
and then he can't open her prison suit
but then it just hits a wall
tonally and completely becomes serious
the rest of the way which was so
strange to me and this had the worst
moment where i said i facepalmed where
aaron is learning how to run again
yikes this one i gave a five but now the
tide turned a bit
ending on positive note here where
episode nine and ten i thought were both
pretty good
as sevens they're both directed by one
of my favorite directors from the
handmaid's tale dana reed
and it shows i think the sharpest
writing and i was like
where was this all season when he asked
this girl kelly on a date
and he awkwardly is asking her i thought
that was great and that's what i felt
like it was missing the whole show i'm
like where was this
and there's a really funny scene in this
episode when lisa kudrow's explaining to
aaron their open relationship and she's
like freaked out
i thought that was great as well this
episode i gave a seven and then i
thought episode 10 continued the trend
this one was written by greg daniels but
the focus group scene with ben schwartz
was pretty good i thought it was
hysterical when he made that pasta for
kelly and there's just no sauce or
cheese on it
a lot of the scenes with him and kelly
really worked well i hope they keep her
going next season and it did get more
serious but i did enjoy it i thought it
worked
where the story line was interesting
where he had to stop the attack
on chyna and i thought it ended on a
funny note when
he saves his daughter and then the mom
shows up but she they're just like
luis like this random woman so i thought
that was funny so i give that a seven as
well
i think there's potential here for this
show for season two this is the greg
daniels track record we're just seeing
over and over again where the first
season is always usually not great with
him but i hope
his history repeats itself where at
least season two should be on the
up i think the show finally got some of
its footing towards the end here but
just way too late
so as a whole i think i'm gonna give
this season
averaging all those ratings i just did
probably about a 4.8
which is really low and disappointing i
just hope for season two
they can fix a lot of this i would say
just
bring down the amount of screen time
normal characters are getting
make dr mallory still there he's
effective he's obviously a great actor
but
just less screen time you got to have
more interesting people around like the
jeromes of the world to make it more
funny and let things just kind of flow
naturally and ha
if you have the funny cast there and
characters and put them in a room
together especially with the guy steve
crawl leading the way
you'll get some good stuff let it just
be more loose next season
and they can do that by just casting
some new people i think you can
really save this show there's potential
here let me know what you thought of
this season down below i'd really love
to hear
all your thoughts i read every comment
and try to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe i can use
any subscriber i can get it really helps
me
i do a bunch of tv reviews movie reviews
and celebrity interviews so you don't
want to miss any of those
and please follow me at steven1 on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time